[Music]
thanks thanks for coming this is my
first time in Warsaw my first time in
Poland actually and it's been lovely
it's been great I've been having a great
time
so thanks the organizer thanks the
organizers for inviting me so today I
want to talk about building people
analytics it's if there's not really an
overarching theme it's just a bunch of
small ideas that I've been thinking
about the past few months and I want to
just share them some of you might find
this topic actually really boring I
talked about data warehouses I talked
about some less sexy analytics but I
think it's still important if if
Catherine yesterday talked about or
talked to the ml group I might talk to
the other the complement the non-mo
group so Who am I I'm Cameron Davidson
Pilon I'm a director of data at Shopify
Shopify not Spotify Shopify is a public
company were based in Canada but we have
offices in Germany and Lithuania as well
and we were looking leading e-commerce
company we have five hundred thousand
merchants now I looked it up last night
even though we're primarily English
based we have about 400 polish merchants
hello and I've been 90 in Warsaw
actually I'm also the author of Bayesian
methods for hackers and it's an open
source book about our how to learn about
how to learn bayesian methods from a
computational point of view first rather
than a mathematical point of view I'm
also the author of lifelines and
lifetimes lifelines the survival
analysis lifetimes is lifetime value
stuff I live in Ottawa Canada I'm a
Canadian normally and let's try that
again that was so close
I'll be back okay sorry about that I'm
currently on a euro trip
we were just in Scotland everyone of
Paris next okay so oh yeah you can
follow along if you want locally using
this URL because the recent changes that
have occurred to me professionally so
I've been a Shopify for four four and a
half years now but helps scale the data
team from six people when I joined to
now 120 people I was leading teams of
teams we were in charge
lots of merchants facing products stuff
around web analytics stuff around the
conversion rate analysis but the truth
was I was getting pretty burnt out on
all that a few months ago I talked to my
boss and I was just telling him how
burnt out or disengaged I was luckily my
boss was was very open to this he's had
episodes like that before so we
suggested a few changes just side note
if you are a manager and your employee
comes to you and you know says they're
not feeling great looking to them and
help them out it's so so important so my
boss was great about this and what he
decided was for me to join this team
called people analytics and think of it
as analytics for HR so we're big enough
competent company now we have about 3100
employees we can start to like look
internally at our own processes like how
are we doing and hiring how are we doing
in internal movements what's our
attrition rate things like that
I'm fortunate at the time the people
analytics team they need to spell those
three of them two of them were Super
Junior one of them was just struggling
trying to like keep her head above water
so what we had was when I joined was we
were extracting all the data from google
spreadsheets and Excel reporting in
operational systems which isn't always
the best thing I really what you want to
do you can't join it with other datasets
you can't you're limited by what that
reporting system has so think of what's
a good example imagine like Gmail had a
reporting suite it'll be pretty garbage
so there was no scalability or
sense of cumulative work when I joined
there's nothing I could say like this is
what we've done in the past year because
that team had been around for a year
what we wanted was control over
collection we wanted to control where
the data came from we wanted a directed
a silic graph of data sets so I could
track like the lineage of data and build
upon that build this like cumulative
work of data sets I want a proper date
of his reporting center because that's
what the business wanted and I wanted
programmatic data curation so being able
to spot anomalies having control having
like my chthonic control over over data
sets and and how they work and how they
interact I basically wanted to build an
ETL so there's that unsexy word ETL so
the business wanted to answer questions
like how many employees were hired last
quarter is diversity of employees
changing over time what is the forecast
for employee growth in 2018 and given
some measure of attrition attrition
means like leaving the company are we
but getting better or worse than last
year so ultimately this was these are
just like counting problems I just need
it to be really good at counting and
this keeps coming up over and over again
so this is a great slide from Monica Roy
Gotti and I'll give you a second to sort
of read it but it's sort of the the
hierarchy of data needs before you start
to do AI or advanced ml at the bottom is
the fundamentals collecting the data and
as you move up you get more and more
advanced we sort of climb the complexity
ladder you can sort of each time you
believe one can order the next one and
climb that complexity ladder this is
great I think there's one piece missing
and and you're always just always
counting at every single step you're
counting at the bottom you're counting
because you need to make sure that
you're not dropping events when you
collect at the aggregation stage you're
either counting over time or you're
computing some rate at the top-level
stage there was a great presentation
just prior to this about counting or
half of it was about counting new open
source libraries devoted just to
counting it was a great blog post by
stitch fix came out a few days ago about
how to
compute word Tyvek using counting just
simple ratios instead of going through
the neural network route so counting is
always a thing we have to do so what
does a new challenge was I need to build
a data warehouse there's again that I'm
sexy word that's really really good at
counting and then we can build on top of
that okay so who here has heard of
double entry bookkeeping this is
familiar a couple all right sweet so so
you the accountants or the accounting
education people kind of added
themselves this is a term from
accounting I recently about a few years
ago kind of caught on to this idea so it
was developed in in Florence during the
Renaissance and it kind of
revolutionized accounting during that
time and even today's modern principles
of accounting are based on this so the
idea is simple for every transaction
from say account 80 to account B you
actually write to time-stamped entries
into your your book one in the forward
Direction one in the reverse direction
so there's the reverse direction housing
a negative transfer amount and so what
happens if what happens is if I want to
sum how much money is in account a how
much money goes into account a it's not
taking to account all the positive
transactions money going into a and all
the negative transactions ie money going
out of a so my net total always stays
the same which makes sense because I'm
just moving money around but I can look
at it so yeah if it's sum of money going
into it's just it's going to account for
the transactions going out so that's
that's the idea with like I have many
accounts and transferring money between
them and I write two entries we can
generalize this and talk about States
instead of accounts so an employee could
be in a certain state so an employee who
is active ie like they're employed they
are working in Toronto Canada
they are developer and they are a
manager they live in one state if
they're
a active employee works in Toronto a
developer not manager they're in a
different state and so I'm sort of
saying like I have many many different
dimensions of what an employee could be
each dimension has a bunch of attributes
and those defying my states and these
are like accounts think of I've lots and
lots of accounts now and now I need to
manage all these accounts okay so if I
had that I can get pretty good at
counting I hope no its back just
wouldn't give it a second great okay so
let's say I have this is a sample
dataset let's say have two workers I
have worker 1 and worker to worker 1 was
hired on January 1st and to a devrel
worker 2 was hired on January 2nd into a
support role and then they moved into
dev role on January 3rd so an internal
movement if you will into hires ok so
how do I set up this double accounting
system ok so take my dataset and I soive
worker or yellow arrow denotes worker 1
and I can see I want to include this
from and 2 columns and these are like
the previous and the next states so when
you're when you join your prior state is
turned off like you're not active
essentially so for worker 1 I have from
active is false because they're not
really active at that time or in the
previous state you know with the red
arrow is for the second worker they went
from support to dev and we can see that
they have this from job support and
they're in the third row there
so kind of you kind of see the the the
Inklings of me trying to like map out
directions where things are going
the next type it's simple you just add
this net column and a bunch of ones
because we're counting I'm gonna be
summing up ones which is equipment
accounting in the financial accounting
sense this might be a money column but
we're just counting so I just used ones
the next step is I now take my data set
this is the double accounting part or
double entry part and
I take my data set and I append it to
itself except I make some changes so the
nets always changed to negative ones
because that's like the negative
transactions and I've also slipped the
from AK or the Fromm's and the two's so
look at the yellow arrow there you can
see in the first row from active is
false and the second row from active is
true those two rows are equivalent I've
just swapped the whatever the work swap
the the states so that's like the other
like that's these are the negative
transaction so at the end here I had
this final data set and it's it's much
larger than the original but it's this
is my double entry bookkeeping data set
okay so this was all the work I want to
do something simple and answer active
employees right now so this is the
sequel entry or sequel query to to
perform that so I'm summing over this
net column and I want to say give me
everyone who's too active is true which
means they they joined or they were
hired and let's see what happened so the
black lines are filtered out from the
false or from the where clause and
notice the net change in the yellow
arrows so that's a one negative one
those are going to net out and that's
kind of the whole idea here those
actually don't matter when it comes to
this query so they just net out and my
answer is to if I sum over what's
remaining cool like that was pretty
alright bit more complicated let's look
at change to support employee employees
over time a few additional pieces I have
a time and a group by in my select query
my sequel query and I have a two job
equals support so I'm a huge dimension
multi-dimensional space of states I'm
sort of cutting two slices one for
support and one for to active is true
and then what that actually looks like
to the query engine it's gonna filter a
bunch of things and I'm left with you
know this final answer Jan 2 is 1 Jan 3
is negative 1 if I accumulate this if I
do like a running sum over that final
column I get essentially employees over
support employees over time
this is this is I look like I can see
some some individuals are excited some
individuals are bored this is kind of
just fundamental like data folding I'm
gonna use this like data origami it's
just like folding data over and over
again to get a result this is like
foundational to a lot of the data sets
we want to work with let's say you work
at a company and you want to look at you
know are how I'm gonna do a
recommendation engine I need to know how
many orders were bought I need to know
who bought it and and when they bought
it so this is kind of a fundamental data
set you need in order to do the more
advanced machine learning I like to
think of this as a data structure
actually so it's a really good principle
in software engineering to like start
with a good data structure so you're not
writing really complicated algorithms
and code on top of that to do what you
actually wanted to do so data structures
will make your query really easy
querying in both like the sequel sense
and the data structure sense so when
you're looking at data warehouse or a
table a sequel table think of it as a
data structure how can I manipulate this
table to make it the right data
structure so I'm not writing these
really gross
you know long-form sequel statements in
order to get what I want the idea to
write a good data structure and not
algorithms it's good software principle
I'm not sure yet if that's also good
like data science principle I don't know
if data scientists would prefer to write
the algorithms or if that's more
maintainable than writing a data
structure I'm not sure okay so that's
cool that's because we built this for
the HR team and they like it they have
their reporting suite now they can
answer their questions we can do
forecast awesome so let's talk about
some more advanced analytics so once we
have this kind of foundational
accounting data set what can we do with
it
so survival analysis I keep talking
about survival analysis over and over
again I think because one I'm
maintaining the open source library for
Python and so I feel like that John the
champion of it or a champion of it and
two I still don't see enough people
using it and so I want to keep like
shoving it down everyone's throat says
it's a really cool cool technique so
it's the study of time to event I will
give like a brief introduction to
survival analysis study of time to event
here are two what we call survival
curves or survival functions we look at
this as this is for this data set it's
the it's the lifespan of global regimes
of political parties so I split it into
democratic and non-democratic regimes it
says something to people analytics I'm
just this is just a fun example so the
the blue line is democratic regimes and
we can see the x axis is the time like
how long that regime lasted for and the
y axis is the probability it will last
longer than the time so for example if I
look at the median of democratic regimes
so take a point five and go over it's
about four years which kind of makes
sense like most democratic regimes
probably exist for four years a
democratic regime is it's like Teresa
Mays regime or Justin Trudeau's regime
or Bush's regime or Obama's regime
things like that
not surprisingly the non-democratic
regimes last a lot longer as we can see
the medians about eight years but we
have this super long tail of
non-democratic regimes which are kind of
the the monarchies the people who say
some power for 20-30 years so we get a
lot of details just from these two
curves we can tell a whole story about
what's the expected lifespan of regimes
how likely are they to exist past forty
years or ten years and so on so survive
analysis is really cool it's it's
generally just the study of time to an
event this durations so how does supply
how does this apply to people analytics
especially within Shopify so we can
measure interesting company durations
that are now top level metrics like time
to attrition like how long before you
leave the company time connects
promotion time to hire the candidate if
you're if time to hire the candidate is
like three weeks that's maybe too fast
and other companies that have a two week
kind of turnover will outperform you so
you want to make sure that that's not
falling
I didn't mention the whole censorship
event or a censorship part of survival
analysis - but censorship occurs when a
observation hasn't finished yet so
Justin Trudeau is a current Canadian
Prime Minister his regime hasn't ended
yet it's he's been in power for two
years three years I know it's at least
three years but I don't know when it
could be three more years it could be
ten more years who knows so that's
censorship these could all be censorship
- there's the current employees at your
company who haven't left yet so they're
censored what else gonna say oh yeah and
one one interesting thing too is you can
be looking at you can break down say
time tonight next promotion buy some
diversity metrics and you can say like
are we promoting women at a healthy rate
compared to men so we can look at things
around that - and these are really
important for HR because they don't want
to be biasing their leadership team for
example so in 2016 we did a general
survey of the entire shopify population
we had all the employees answer some
questions there were about 70 questions
in total that was in late 2016 since
then people have left the company that's
just natural but now we have a cool
opportunity to look back at their
responses in 2016 and look at their
attrition rate or those survival curves
of of these of a condition on their
answers so we did a looked at all 70
questions we did a survival regression
using Cox proportional hazards model and
looked for significant questions
questions that predicted or had School
Certificate significance that people
would churn based on their responses
this is one that came up
I've fudged the data but you get the
idea so how confident do you feel but
the following thing in your team so
taking risks so clearly you can look at
this and see people who aren't confident
taking risks are at a higher likelihood
of churning this is really important for
for a charter to see so this was like
create insight and analysis we gave to
HR
they can out take this data and give or
develop tools for the managers and
leaders of Shopify to encourage
risk-taking or encourage encourage
recognizing when someone doesn't feel
comfortable taking risks
generally generally we want our
attrition rate to be high or sorry low
I'm looking at these curves I want to be
high but so we'll go out of our way to
make sure people feel comfortable taking
these risks there are a bunch of
questions we kind of analyzed then this
was just one of them so I'll switch to
talking about conjoint analysis oops and
this is the study of what do humans
really want and again dealing with
people analytics I can't just measure
them I would in web analytics were so
spoiled because we have things like IP
address we have like user agent we have
referrers
UTM campaigns we have all this metadata
about a visitor visiting a web site but
with with employees and humans we don't
have that people don't just naturally
give up you know where they just came
from before they arrive at your location
so we often rely on surveys so conjoint
analysis is one way to use survey
methods to understand what people
actually want so the general question
that came up from HR was which benefit
package to employees prefer benefits and
tech companies you may have noticed sort
of this weird kind of ratchet you can
only ever add benefits you can't really
remove them very easily you have this
like entire industry adding new benefits
like free lunches or you know unlimited
vacation or or whatever and it's hard to
go back it's hard to roll back these
these benefits but some benefits don't
really matter to employee retention or
to employee interest and so we were
trying to understand what are the the
core benefits that people really like
and we can't just again we can't just
ask them do you like benefit X because
on a scale of one to ten because they'll
just give us 10 10 10 10 10 like no one
wants to see their benefits be removed
which is totally fair that's that's
human nature
but we do want to know
if we had to change benefits that we had
to introduce new benefits what's most
effective so this is useful for hiring
strategies a new new candidate might be
looking at two companies and they might
want to compare benefit packages given
all else is equal and we can also see if
it significantly reduce costs if we can
remove benefits that no one really cares
about that's a bonus we can spend that
money elsewhere so let's do like a
little exercise let's look at this
survey so would you prefer package A or
B benefit package a or b so package a
has where's time okay coming back so a
package a has lunches yoga and a gym
budget and package B has lunches and
some dental let's see I like yoga and
lunches more than dental so I pick that
I picked a package a next one might be a
little a little bit different so package
a has yoga beer and gym no free lunches
but package B has lunches and yoga I
love those free smoothies or whatever so
I choose package B again a package B
okay so why why is why do I like this
survey method why am I doing this over
say asking people on the scale of one to
ten so this is much more natural to how
humans choose humans walk into or they
they walk into a store and they want to
buy lemonade they're not gonna rate
lemonade between one and ten and she was
a higher one they're gonna take those
two lemonade's and look at the sugar
content they're gonna look at the
sourness look at the brand and then make
that choice that's a very natural human
decision to make that binary choice
secondly it forces the respondent to do
a trade-off I can't just give them all
the benefits they have to choose and
selectively choose based on their
interest what benefit package they
prefer and thirdly if we fit this into a
regression model which I'll get to later
we can look at the measure of importance
for each benefit so I could do more
statistical techniques to get more
information about what people actually
like so how do we do this this is this
conjoint analysis part so we kind of
create were called profiles profile one
for example has lunches and yoga two has
lunches and dental and so on and then I
sent up surveys like I had before I
could do more than one profile per
survey but in this case I just chose
binary like just two options so in
survey 1 its profile a versus profile 2
and so on
let's just let's go back for a second if
you had say n and different benefits
then you might have like a combinatorial
explosion which is expected but you can
do some like interesting factorial
design to sort of reduce your space and
sort of figure out like a much smaller
sample or a sample set ok so step 2 is
then get the survey results and that's
just a company-wide survey users will
answer a few of these surveys and they
choose a bunch of different profiles so
that's just like the necessary step to
collect data step 3 is to build that
statistical model that I mentioned
before so mathematically a profile is
just a binary vector one if that benefit
is present and zero if it's not present
so unknown is a coefficient vector
called it beta for now and my model is
so actually the probability of choosing
a profile is the dot product of the beta
and the binary vector and then I softmax
it so mathematic mathematically it looks
like below pk P subscript K is the
probability I choose the case
profile if I'm presented with a few of
them so in our case is just K mu one or
two and XK is the profile of the first
or second in our case binary
representations and then I just softmax
it so it's like a probability so I can
fit this using either gradient descent
or MC MC cool extension of this and
something that I'm working with is if I
had individual betas for each user user
so I have a hierarchical model and each
user has their own beta and I can look
at an individual's in
wrists I have to use MCMC for that but
that's all the better in my opinion and
then interpret interpretations so I've
bowled and interpreted because it's the
hot word of the day of the week okay
sorry
and I'm like its back great so the
magnitude of elements in beta can be
seen as a measure of the importance so
it's something spikes or something is
really high the individuals that the
population really likes that benefit
we're also giving a correlation matrix
of all the benefits so we can look for
clusters within that correlation matrix
and that itself is a really good benefit
package that people really like we also
now have a framework for optimizing
employee satisfaction given some budget
constraint so if finance says we can
only spend X dollars per employee per
her for the benefits we now have a
really nice linear programming exercise
where we could just optimize employee
satisfaction given that constraint and
so like the previous presentation I'm
also kind of semi announcing something
today was already kind of open but it's
called lifestyles which is a way to do
conjoint analysis in Python it's built
upon PI MC 3 it's very pre-alpha right
now I don't even have an API for it yet
there's some Doc's but it's basically
just a repository for some conjoint
analysis models at the moment the idea
is to eventually plug-and-play like any
other great Python Python package you
give it data and it spits out the
analysis kind of the interpretations
coefficients the convergence results
things like that so you can make this
really easy there's not many other
libraries doing this sure I can't think
of any open source libraries there's a
few companies trying like selling the
software for like thousands of dollars I
know like our like Shopify did some or
had some consultants come in and they
did conjoint analysis for us this is
before my time
and it cost us like you lots of money so
think there's there
money in this in this stuff too so yeah
it's cool yeah so I'm I've kind of
settled on the life prefix for for all
my packages those lifelines lifestyles
and lifetimes so that's kind of where
I'm going with cool so in conclusion
just some things up I think counting is
easy if you build the right data
structures it's important to get that
right and then as we saw like counting
is still so fundamental of every part of
that complexity ladder people analytics
is is really darn cool if your company's
big enough to support people analytics
team check it out
I'm it's it's ice I've been like
thinking about different models for the
company and my current model of thinking
is the company's like a small country
and I want to employ I'm like the
economist of that country I want to play
different economic models to the company
things around like you know infant
mortality rate is kind of like an
analogy I'm making with AK attrition
anyways and then thirdly there are
really interesting statistical methods
still being developed that aren't
necessarily deep learning or advanced
like girl networks on that last point I
was kind of surprised about PI data
Warsaw there were a lot of advanced
other NLP or advanced like deep learning
stuff what do you think is fine but I
don't want that to become I don't want
to ignore the other part of a PI data
the other part of data science I don't
want us to see things like a bee testing
as solved because it's definite solved I
don't want us to see machine learning
ethics as solved because that's not
solved I don't want to see fundamentals
like data warehousing and ETLs and like
cool data structures as solved because
again that those things aren't solved
they're still like really really hard
problems there and they're super
exciting and I don't want to like jump
the gun and get right into NLP or not
NLP and deep learning when there's still
like really interesting other problems
that are I think as a community we
haven't necessarily solved yet
cool that's a little yeah this great
time so that's all I have thank you
thank you so much come around we have
time for questions at least few minutes
yeah I have a question about model you
have described with this double
bookkeeping because what made you decide
to rebuild it from I think what would be
the simplest form by having two types
with one containing your employees and
the other their history and I think that
every example I have talked about could
be covered by it but probably the
queries would be harder but what made
you decide to build it completely
different that would be simplest SQL
approach I think it was it was that the
the point you mentioned where the
queries would be the sequel would be
just harder it's it's easier to make a
mistake when your queries are you know a
hundred lines long or more I've seen
queries that are like you know kilobytes
long which is crazy it's easy to make
mistakes so you want to push as much of
that logic into the ETL portion as you
can it's easier to test there it also
allows for more flexibility I think it's
easier to add things like and I can add
a new dimension say I wanted to add a
new are they on like a leave of absence
for example I kind of that dimension
much easier in this model then like
having to add it to like a different
kind of data set it was just like more
conceptually simple I think yeah um if I
don't that answers your question but it
just made things a lot simpler or like
down the line cut you feel like teaching
new analysts coming on board how to
query this table or how to like use this
table or how to use this data set they
can get up and running much quicker so
was it was saving time later I think and
saving errors later
next one so on the topic of life and on
the topic of balance you mentioned you
may have had experience with like
burnout and that kind of thing and
that's also something that's kind of
common in this food work in general so
any tips on thoughts are on that for
anyone that might be relevant I think
it's important to yeah talk to your
manager they should be as a manager and
if you see if you are a manager you
should be very comfortable talking about
that and be very open to it if your
employee needs a couple days off like
that's fine I probably sort of realized
I was kind of approaching burnout at the
right time maybe a bit too late but at
the right time um I could sense it kind
of it's very obvious in retrospect what
was happening but at the time it just
felt like maybe there's a bad week or
maybe it's just like a bad month that
I'm having but it's not it's probably
let me keep going on so maybe I maybe
that's the advice if you have a bad week
that's a signal if you have two bad
weeks like it's probably going to
continue don't keep putting it off don't
keep saying like oh it's it's gonna go
away eventually it's probably a problem
and then yeah talk to your manager talk
to your lead about that if your
company's not comfortable with like you
changing roles or taking like a couple
days off like the company is very soft
motivated in their in their own
interests so yeah like your company
should be very comfortable with you
taking a different role or taking time
off or something thank you
I can have seen him All Hands god this
one
how could you tell us more a little bit
about technical infrastructure or data
warehousing environment especially what
I'm interested in as already was
mentioned in previous question like the
dissolution especially the counting
table seems kinda non-standard it seems
difficult to expose to business users so
they can use them in the front and bi
system so I'm interested how it works
like at your environment what are the
tools you're using how you're exposing
this analyzes to the business users yeah
so maybe people analytics like HR data's
a particular case a unique case we
actually don't expose the raw underlying
tables to end-users because there's like
lots of sensitive data in there we kind
of keep it to ourselves sambal to expose
graphs or charts or reporting to them so
the analyst on my team are very
comfortable using it but no one else
kind of deals with that however that's
like the people analytics data warehouse
we have a whole other data team at
Shopify working on like other parts of
the the data stack most end-users
I think it's like a fallacy for I think
self-serve bi is a fallacy I think it's
never possible and it should always be
done by like a data person or something
like you know bi analyst something like
that
so they'll be able to grow that kind of
double-entry accounting double-entry
bookkeeping like pretty quickly most non
bi people won't so i mean our most text
our tech stack at Shopify is we'll have
the data warehouse and then mode which
is a really great reporting SAS company
that basically it's like write sequel
get charts kind of idea it's called mode
of analytics in front of our data
warehouse and that publishes like
reports and graphs and stuff like that
we have last question here well it's
actually it's a comment because with
respect to the first question because we
have certain complexity in our problem
and we can put this complexity either in
the algorithm or in the data that's one
of the basic things from donald knuth
book
algorithm plus data structures are equal
to program so it's a very known fact and
in this case I did very similar things
with calculations of time like attrition
or our lives etc and if you look at this
at this model it will be obvious that
with this double entry bookkeeping it's
easy to to see if given event should be
calculate should contribute to the sum
or not if you don't do it then you don't
know looking at just add even you need
to look at the event and at something
before or after it if you look if you do
double enter by bookkeeping you just
look at the event and you know if it's
contribution if it's positive or
negative and it really simplifies both
counting and for example time
calculation and as it was in my case
right right one thing I did I forgot one
example I didn't show off which is super
relevant is I can now look at state
transitions so I want to know everyone
who went from support to dev that's like
I can do if you call the table it's like
from job equals support to job equals
dev I'm literally riding out sequel in
my head and it's like I know that state
transition like and if I had like the
raw kind of summary tables of like this
person at this time was this I have to
like look back somehow in my sequel or
in my something-or-other and ask okay
but were they before this and then do
this really complicated kind of thing
you're basically moving all that logic
into the sequel which is just too hard
but oh yeah you can look at you can be
more specific with what you actually
want I think that was one of your points
yeah okay thank you so much hello
decomposers thank you
you
you